[Musique]
depuis juin 2020 et les premiers impacts
du coc vite sur l'économie la fed n'a
pas lésiné sur l'injection de mener sur
les marchés près de 120 milliards de
dollars par mois afin que la bourse
américaine et par ricochet les bourses
mondiales ne s'effondre pas des achats
d'actifs massifs qui pourraient bientôt
se réduire à en croire nous compte rendu
de la dernière réunion de la fed fin
juillet ce qu'on appelle les minutes 13
membres du comité de la réserve fédérale
sur dix huit seraient favorables à un
thé polling qu'une réduction progressive
de rachats d'actifs sur les marchés sept
membres de plus qu'au mois de mars
dernier en bref la fête pourrait bientôt
enfin d'ici 2023 fermer un peu peut-être
beaucoup les robinet d'argent frais il
faut dire et on en a déjà parlé
plusieurs fois ici que le cosy doha
démontré plus que jamais une déconnexion
flagrante entre des marchés soutenus
comme jamais par les banques centrales
et l'économie réelle bien mal en point
des marchés qui ont d'ailleurs assez mal
accueilli cette nouvelle
les indices boursiers ont tous clôturé à
la baisse après la publication de ce
compte rendu de la fed reste à savoir si
la fed rejoindra les actes à la parole
et si les marchés pour un jour se passer
des aides massives des banques centrales